notre histoire commence
il était une fois trois frères qui n'en
menaient pas très large oui bah votre
mère va à la fin d'affaires plus cher
soudain je voyais défiler ma vie dans
laquelle il ne se passait rien du tout
pour la première fois de ma vie je me
posais la question on appelle assez
profité aussi évidemment cette
entreprise réclamaient quelques petits
arrangements tu veux avec ton pull
parce que c'est vraiment vrai certes
s'avérer progrès elle et d'une ergonomie
corporelle et y raconte la [ __ ] ticket
de métro 8 ou 10 nov
tu peux arrêter d'appeler la [ __ ]
l'hôpital je suis je suis là à la
cafétéria
tous ces noms avec comme un sucre le
petit problème c'est que nous histoire
rang des envies légèrement à fleur de
peau aussi j'ai une aventure seul truc
c'est patricia j'ai un peu promis la
fidélité voilà la société nantaise
affinités que tu te goures à tourner
quatre ans
méfie toi c'est les 3 p'tits cochons ces
mecs là je suis avec le troisième cochon
l'aîné celui qui a une maison solide
je te propose un très bon deal
quand je suis porte avions et toi tu
veux poser quand tu veux pas voir de
quoi exactement
je pense que j'attendais pour être
célibataire se faire larguer bon
l'apport de ce que je suis devenu un
homme est libre un insoumis un hug
tremblay mouchoirs troubles et ces
femmes là oui vous n'êtes pas trop cuite
à mag est d'accord